dormir ça fait partie des petits
plaisirs de la vie on va bien dormir
parce que dormir c'est pas toujours de
tout repos
les insomnies les cauchemars les
ronflements l'apnée du sommeil
vous connaissez mais est ce que vous
connaissez les autres troubles du
sommeil chelou qui peuvent venir gâcher
vos nuits et celle des autres on
commence avec la star incontestée des
troubles du sommeil le killian mba [ __ ]
parasomnie j'ai nommé le somnambulisme
comme la majorité des troupes dont on a
parlé aujourd'hui c'est donc ce qu'on
appelle une parasomnie c'est-à-dire un
trouble du sommeil avec comportement
anormal
à ne pas confondre avec les dix ovni qui
sont des anomalies de la quantité de la
qualité de l'horaire du sommeil ça
arrive dans une phase de sommeil profond
ça peut durer jusqu'à une demi heure
et contrairement à ce qu'on pense c'est
pas dangereux pour la santé du
somnambule de le réveiller
mais ça peut être dangereux pour celui
ou celle qui le réveille parce que le
somnambule
il peut être un petit peu désorientés
ils risquent de se sentir menacés et
d'essayer de se défendre mais comme ça
peut aussi être dangereux de laisser
faire n'importe quoi
le mieux c'est de le raccompagner au lit
tranquillement la sunny loki le nom vous
dit peut-être rien du tout mais en vrai
vous connaissez la somme de l'authie
c'est le fait de parler en dormant c'est
différent du somnambulisme parce que la
personne ne se lève pas assez son lit et
que ça ne perturbe pas la qualité de son
sommeil
mais ça peut être gênant si elle dort
pas seul parce que ça peut aller de
petit chuchotements jusqu'à des
hurlements voir des crises de larmes et
c'est aussi à la fois plus rares et plus
fréquent que le somnambulisme
parce qu'on estime que 70% d'entre nous
parle parfois en dormant et la vraie
somilo qu'il s'était fréquentes et
régulières elles ne touchent que 1,5
pour cent des gens alors que le
somnambulisme ses 10 à 15% des enfants
entre 8 et 12 ans et 2 à 4% des adultes
contre l'ac milan qui l'a pas grand
chose à faire à part peut-être des
bouchons d'oreille pour la personne qui
dort à côté
la sexomnie bon là pas besoin de faire
d'études étymologique approfondi la
sexomnie c'est faire du sexe pendant son
sommeil il ya plusieurs niveaux
ça peut être faire des bruits en dormant
negro
mon des gémissements de tubes sexuelle
c'est une forme de ce qu'on appelle la
cata très ému je vous vois sourire je le
comprends 1
mais en vrai la sexomnie ça peut poser
des vrais problèmes de consentement que
ce soit avec le conjoint ou la conjointe
ou avec d'autres personnes la section il
faut savoir que ça a été au coeur de
plusieurs procès la paralysie du sommeil
là je pense que ceux qui connaissent
sont en train de voir un peu flou parce
que c'est rarement un bon souvenir
on se réveille on peut pas bouger on a
l'impression d'étouffer or sans une
espèce d'angoissé voire de menaces
parfois avec des hallucinations qui
donne l'impression qu'il ya une présence
malfaisante dans la pièce pas ou tarifs
pendant une phase de sommeil paradoxal
c'est une phase pendant laquelle le
cerveau est très actif puisque c'est la
phase pendant laquelle on rêve mais
c'est aussi une phase pendant laquelle
un neurotransmetteur à nous tous nos
muscles au repos ça se passe souvent au
moment de l'endormissement ou du réveil
ça touche environ 20% des personnes et
disons le clairement ça n'est jamais
dangereux tout ce qu'il ya à faire dans
ces cas là bas c'est de se dire ça déjà
et d'attendre que ça passe
parce que ça passe en quelques secondes
voire quelques minutes mais ça passe
toujours
c'est juste que votre cerveau s'est
réveillée avant votre corps l'ivresse du
sommeil on appelle ça aussi l'éveil
confusionnel le pitch on est beaucoup de
temps à se réveiller complètement genre
plusieurs dizaines de minutes au lieu de
2 ou 3 normalement
et pendant ce temps là on fait n'importe
quoi on dit n'importe quoi
un peu comme si on avait trop forcer à
la plage ça toucherait une personne sur
sept le plus souvent celles qui dorment
peu ou qui dorment beaucoup et qui se
réveille de façon brutale genre avec un
réveil matin un peu binaire par exemple
ça peut se manifester par des
comportements agressifs et ça peut être
dangereux pour soi ou pour l'entourage
nous ça peut juste être marrant comme
brest ou le syndrome de la tête qui
explose oui et non calmez vous dit comme
ça ça fait flipper mais la tête d'
explose pas vraiment c'est juste un truc
qui apparaît dans la phase entre l'éveil
et le sommeil et qui consiste à entendre
un bruit violent comme une explosion
donc où des cris
un coup de feu une porte qui claque etc
c'est ni dangereux ni douloureux mais
c'est flippant
il ya peu d'études sur le sujet donc on
sait pas trop ni d'où ça vient ni
comment ça marche là encore le mieux
c'est de se dire que c'est rien c'est
pas grave
éventuellement de faire de la méditation
avant de s'endormir et ça peut suffire
les hallucinations it nago gic c'est un
terme général pour définir les
hallucinations sensorielle qui
apparaissent au moment de
l'endormissement
ça peut être des hallucinations
visuelles au revoir des monstres ou des
insectes dans la chambre des
hallucinations auditives ou des
sensations de mouvement involontaire
c'est comme quand on a l'impression
qu'on ne tombe quand on s'endort et que
ça nous réveille en sursaut
on pense que cette sensation là c'est le
corps qui s'endort avant le cerveau du
coup tous nos muscles se relâchent et
comme on en a conscience ça donne cette
impression de chute
là encore c'est pas dangereux mais c'est
pénible les parasomnie tous ces trucs
dont on vient de parler c'est parfois
d'origine génétique mais on sait aussi
qu'il ya un certain nombre de choses qui
augmente le risque dans la voir comme le
manque de sommeil ou le décalage horaire
le stress certaines maladies ou des
médicaments et bien sûr l'alcool les
drogues etc
ça c'est une première piste pour se
soigner pour le reste il ya aussi des
centres spécialisés dans les troubles du
sommeil parce que dormir c'est bien mais
dormir bien c'est mieux